so if you get married what do you want
that marriage to look like oh um if I
get married I would like I would like to
have a guy that I can try I look at it
similar to my relationship with like my
dad which I don't know if that's is that
weird I don't know I was thinking about
this but like some will have a problem
with how you worded it but it's up to
you it's your word okay because I think
of my dad and same with my brother like
I'll give you an example I trust my dad
so much I hate accounting my dad makes
me do the accounting myself every month
and every month I'm like why can't we
hire an accountant I don't understand
why I do this myself and my dad's like
look it you have to know your numbers
you have to do my dad's like that too
yeah and I'm like fine and I do it
because I trust my dad because I'm like
my dad wouldn't like steer me insane
with uh my brother Adam it's really
similar too and that's kind of a
relationship that I'd like to have
similar with my husband where even if
like I disagree with him it's like you
trust his judgment